These rocks are 101, so we have endogenous toxins such as recycled vitamins and things
that we need to get out of the body thyroid hormones, and we have insogenous things known
as xenobiotics, and those things need to get out, there can be drugs, they can be supplements,
they can be heavy metals, they can be chemicals, but basically they're going to be in your blood
stream right here, right, all these toxins, they need to go into the liver cell, right,
so this is the liver cell, we're just going to for simplicity sake, we're going to talk
about the liver being the main organ and it is of detoxification, we won't talk about
the kidney, but so these toxins that are hanging out here they need to go into the liver,
that movement into the liver is referred to as phase zero detoxification, and that was
actually just discovered in 2008, so I thought time is something, because I never heard
of that before, but Dr. Brian Walsh talks about phase zero, so it's got to go in through some
membrane transporters, and then once it gets inside the cell the toxin has to go through
phase one detoxification, which can be oxidation, hydrolysis and reduction, so that makes it
a little bit more reactive, and then we're going to go into phase two, which is the workhorse
of the congenuity enzymes, and you're going to have sulfation, granadation, methylation,
all those things are going to hook onto that toxin, so that it can be more water soluble
and get excreted, so typically after that the toxin will go into the BC, the bio-caniculous,
and that's where the toxin is going to flow into your intestine and hopefully hit the toilet,
right, so that right there is called phase three, so the movement zero, one and two, and the
toxins move into the bio-caniculous, so there's your review, so what I learned, what interested
about a year ago, was that the movement that I just said of those toxins that have gone
through phase two, so they're water soluble, meaning they're ready to be put into the bio,
because the bio is mostly water, and they're ready to be pushed in from the liver saw into
the bio-caniculous, they can actually get held up, and that movement right there, it's a three-part
movement, and again if you want more information on this, I've done a ton of podcasts, air
can I do a seminar in this, so that's online as well, but that movement of that water soluble
toxin, it goes through the MRP2 transport protein channel, so it's like a door, so the door opens,
and then the toxin will go into the bio, and then hopefully go into the intestine into the toilet,
and you also need that movement coupled with bio, with the bio salts, so you need to be making
your bio, and there's genetic defects that can hinder you from making bio, you can have problems
with the sedalation, and it's a little bit complicated, but really you need to be able to make your bio,
and then you need to be able to get those toxins into the bio-caniculous, and thirdly, to make the
bio nice and not sludgy, you need phosphol coli, because if you don't have phosphol coli,
your bio is going to be really sludgy, and you hear about that when women get fair fat and
40, they get their gallbladders taken out, well you need estrogen to make your phosphol
coline, if you don't have the phosphol coli, your blood sludgy and stuck, and you can't get your
toxins out, and I really think that the one of the reasons people can't lose weight is because when
phase 2.5 isn't working, where are your toxins going to go? They're going to go right back into
your bloodstream, and they're going to have to be sequestered in fat, because they don't have
to go. Your escape plan, it's broken, it's just broken, so it's not working.
So the million dollar question is what limits toxin excretion,
bile, and phosphol coline production is excretion, and that is called phase 2.5, what limits it?
Our body does this work of getting it into the cell, the toxin in the cell, going through phase 1,
going through phase 2, it's all ready to go, it's just like a bow on it, and then it's just stuck,
and it can't get through the door has been closed. What's the number one thing that causes that
inflammation? So if your patient is inflamed, their natural ability to get toxins out, the shut.
And when I read that, when I started studying the literature of the science,
I gave a standing on some big shoulders, Decker and Shay did a wonderful paper about those MRP-2
transporters, the door, I was like, wow, that makes sense, because when I had lime and I was
really sick, I would go to well-meaning practitioners, and they would put me on nutraceuticals and things
that were operating my phase 1 and phase 2, and they're like, we're going to push those detox pathways,
we're going to push those, I'm like, I feel like you're pushing me into the grave, because I feel
horrible, I'm like, what is going on? Well, I was inflamed, I was completely inflamed, I had a chronic
biotoxin running around in my blood, and my gut wasn't massed, and other things were, you know,
not right in my system, I was under-neurushed, and it was closed, the door was closed.
So those toxins went right back into my blood, I take the glutathione, I'm like, I feel like
death. So the glutathione was called making more, I was conjugating more toxins, but they were
ending right up back in my bloodstream, and I think that was what a Herk's is, Herk's can be a Herk's
action, and overlonged that ability.